Psychologists are experts in behavior and mental health, but can they have an impact on our physical health? Behavioral health teams working in tandem with primary care positions can improve outcomes and reduce cost. So how does it work? We speak with one psychologist who focuses on patient-centered and integrated health care, providing more comprehensive and coordinated care for patients and their families. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Parinda Kotri is a chief clinical officer at Cherokee Health Systems, a comprehensive community health care organization with 56 clinical sites in Tennessee.
心理学家是行为和心理健康方面的专家，但他们能对我们的身体健康产生影响吗？与初级保健医生协同工作的行为健康团队可以改善治疗效果并降低成本。那么它是如何运作的呢？我们采访了一位专注于以患者为中心和综合医疗保健的心理学家，她为患者及其家人提供更全面、更协调的护理。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。帕琳达·科特里是切诺基卫生系统的首席临床官，这是一个在田纳西州拥有56个临床站点的综合社区医疗保健组织。
Dr. Kotri provides oversight and guidance on blended primary care and behavioral health services within the organization. In addition, she trains, consults, and presents extensively on integrated care. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Katri. Thank you very much. We hear a lot today about integrated health care. Are patient-centered health care and integrated health care the same thing? Well, they certainly are related, but they are not the same thing.
科特里博士负责监督和指导该组织内的混合初级保健和行为健康服务。此外，她还就综合护理进行了广泛的培训、咨询和演讲。感谢您加入我们，科特里博士。非常感谢。我们今天经常听到综合医疗保健。以患者为中心的医疗保健和综合医疗保健是一回事吗？嗯，它们当然是相关的，但它们不是一回事。
Patient-centered care is really about a model of care that focuses on comprehensive, holistic care that is coordinated, provides access, and emphasizes quality and safety. And so a patient-centered care is really an overall model of care and approach to care. Integrated care is a pathway, if you will, to patient-centered care. So integrated care is an approach to care in which primary care, medical clinicians, and behavioral health clinicians work closely together as part of a team with patients and families using a very systematic and cost-effective approach for a defined population. and so that care may address mental health and substance abuse issues,
以患者为中心的护理实际上是一种护理模式，侧重于全面、整体的护理，这种护理是协调的、提供可及性的，并强调质量和安全。因此，以患者为中心的护理实际上是一种整体的护理模式和方法。综合护理可以被视为通往以患者为中心护理的途径。因此，综合护理是一种护理方法，在这种方法中，初级保健医生、医疗临床医生和行为健康临床医生作为团队的一部分，与患者及其家人密切合作，为特定人群使用非常系统且具有成本效益的方法。因此，这种护理可以解决心理健康和药物滥用问题，
health behaviors, including their contribution to chronic medical illness, life stressors, crises, stress-related physical symptoms, health care utilization. So, for example, what is a patient-centered medical home? So a patient-centered medical home is a model of care that focuses on concepts of, of course, number one, patient-centered care in which the patient is really a partner with their health care team. The care is also comprehensive, and that means that all of the patient's health care needs, including lifestyle management, prevention, wellness, as well as chronic and acute conditions,
健康行为，包括它们对慢性内科疾病、生活压力源、危机、压力相关的身体症状、医疗保健利用的影响。那么，例如，什么是“以患者为中心的医疗之家”？以患者为中心的医疗之家是一种护理模式，它关注的核心概念当然首先是以患者为中心的护理，在这种护理中，患者确实是其医疗团队的合作伙伴。护理也是全面的，这意味着患者所有的医疗保健需求，包括生活方式管理、预防、健康，以及慢性病和急性病，
are taken care of. So it's much more comprehensive than just focusing in one specific system like your respiratory system or only a very certain set of issues in your body. It's really designed to cover all aspects of your health. The care is also expected to be coordinated, so that means that in a patient-centered medical home, you are going to have a team of providers who are linking all the dots for you, if you will. If you have to go to different specialists, if you have to get different labs, all the different
都得到了照顾。因此，它比仅仅关注呼吸系统等特定系统或身体中某些特定问题要全面得多。它旨在涵盖您健康的各个方面。护理也被要求是协调的，这意味着在以患者为中心的医疗之家，您将拥有一支为您连接所有环节的医疗服务提供者团队。如果您必须去看不同的专家，如果您必须进行不同的化验，所有不同的
elements of the broader healthcare system are coordinated within this patient-centered home. And then certainly quality and safety is emphasized that because the patient-centered medical home is such a core part and almost a cornerstone in someone's health care, we really want to make sure that it is of the highest quality possible and that it's safe. So I have a primary care physician. Does that mean my care is being delivered in a patient-centered care model? It's certainly a first step to getting patient-centered care is to have a primary care physician. But, again, the core elements of how the care is provided, is it being patients, is it really engaging you as a partner?
更广泛医疗保健系统的要素都在这个以患者为中心的家中得到协调。当然，质量和安全也受到强调，因为以患者为中心的医疗之家是某人医疗保健的核心部分，几乎是基石，我们确实希望确保它是尽可能高质量且安全的。那么，我有初级保健医生。这是否意味着我的护理是以患者为中心的护理模式提供的？拥有初级保健医生当然是获得以患者为中心护理的第一步。但是，同样，护理提供方式的核心要素是，它是否以患者为中心，是否真的让您作为合作伙伴参与其中？
Is it comprehensive? Is it coordinated? Do you have easy access to your provider 24 hours a day, seven days a week? Is there a strong commitment to quality and safety? All of those components have to be there. So having a primary care physician is certainly the first step, but it's not the only step in getting good patient-centered care. You know, patient-centered care is sometimes referred to as patient-and-family-centered health care.
它全面吗？它协调吗？您是否能24小时、每周7天轻松联系到您的医疗服务提供者？对质量和安全是否有坚定的承诺？所有这些组成部分都必须具备。因此，拥有初级保健医生当然是第一步，但它不是获得良好以患者为中心护理的唯一一步。你知道，以患者为中心的护理有时被称为“以患者和家庭为中心的医疗保健”。
You know, why is that? People have begun to realize that patients, individuals don't live in isolation, that we all have social networks and partnerships and relationships that are incredibly important to us. Not only are they important to us personally, they're important to our health. Many of us live with other people. We live perhaps with our parents, siblings, partners, children, extended family, friends. All of these people construct a very important social network that has a very strong impact on any person, overall health status. Let's talk about some particularly pressing health conditions, you know, obesity
你知道，为什么会这样？人们已经开始意识到，患者、个人并不是孤立生活的，我们都有对我们极其重要的社会网络、伙伴关系和人际关系。它们不仅对我们个人很重要，对我们的健康也很重要。我们许多人与他人住在一起。我们可能与父母、兄弟姐妹、伴侣、孩子、大家庭成员、朋友住在一起。所有这些人构成了一个非常重要的社会网络，对任何人的整体健康状况都有非常强烈的影响。让我们谈谈一些特别紧迫的健康状况，你知道，肥胖
and diabetes. They're critical health problems for a large segment of the population. Will patient-centered care help reverse the trends you think for these two diseases? Well, certainly the research data and our clinical experience seems to indicate that having patient-centered care is going to have a profound impact. on chronic health conditions as well as overall lifestyle behaviors such as the kinds of behaviors that can lead to obesity. So when we think about really the pandemic of obesity, we have to think about all the different components that are involved, diet, nutrition, certainly genetic vulnerability or
和糖尿病。它们是很大一部分人群的关键健康问题。你认为以患者为中心的护理有助于扭转这两种疾病的趋势吗？嗯，当然，研究数据和我们的临床经验似乎表明，以患者为中心的护理将产生深远的影响。对慢性健康状况以及整体生活方式行为，例如可能导致肥胖的行为类型。因此，当我们真正思考肥胖大流行时，我们必须考虑所涉及的所有不同组成部分，饮食、营养、当然还有遗传易感性或
predispositions, and also with diabetes, diet, activity level, overall self-management of health. They're all important concepts and all important aspects of health. So if we have a model of care that's able to very aggressively partner with a person in addressing kind of the full scope of factors associated with obesity, for example, how you eat, how active you are, and you have someone partnering with you in this process and really walking alongside you in this process. certainly we have a much stronger likelihood of addressing this problem and helping someone manage this problem and address it in effective manner than if you don't have that team or that support around you.
倾向，对于糖尿病，还有饮食、活动水平、整体健康自我管理。它们都是重要的概念，也是健康的重要方面。因此，如果我们有一种护理模式，能够非常积极地与个人合作，解决与肥胖相关的所有因素，例如，你如何饮食、你有多活跃，并且在这个过程中有人与你合作，真正陪伴你走过这个过程。当然，与没有团队或支持围绕在你身边相比，我们更有可能解决这个问题，并帮助某人以有效的方式管理和解决这个问题。
And certainly for diabetes, this is even more so the case because within a patient-centered medical home, a patient really partners with their health care team in setting self-management goals for themselves. We recognize that good management of diabetes, good management of glucose requires constant vigilance, checking sugars, taking insulin if that's prescribed, making significant changes in diet, making significant changes in lifestyle behavior such as smoking and activity level, and to expect what person to do it on their own is, you know, certainly I think challenging and we've recognized that these are major changes. And, you know, if we can certainly work together and we have partners to help us kind of walk this path to cheer us on when things are challenging to give us feedback from lab results
对于糖尿病，情况更是如此，因为在以患者为中心的医疗之家内，患者真正与他们的医疗团队合作，为自己设定自我管理目标。我们认识到，良好的糖尿病管理、良好的血糖管理需要持续的警惕，检查血糖、如果处方要求则注射胰岛素、在饮食上做出重大改变、在吸烟和活动水平等生活方式行为上做出重大改变，期望一个人独自完成这些是，你知道，当然我认为具有挑战性，我们已经认识到这些是重大的改变。而且，你知道，如果我们当然可以一起工作，并且有合作伙伴来帮助我们走这条路，在困难时为我们加油，从化验结果中给我们反馈，
to make sure that they're available to us whenever we feel like we're not doing as well, that's going to, of course, create a much better environment for addressing these two very dangerous health conditions. Now, the health system you work in, Cherokee Health System, is a leader in providing patient-centered care. Can you tell us about how that works? So Cherokee Health Systems is a federally qualified health center and a community mental health center. We have a clinical service delivery model that has a paradigm of integrated health care services. And what that means on the ground is that when people come to our clinic, In fact, even when they call in, all of their health care needs are assessed.
确保在我们觉得做得不够好时他们能随时为我们提供帮助，这当然会创造一个更好的环境来解决这两种非常危险的健康状况。现在，您工作的卫生系统，切诺基卫生系统，是提供以患者为中心护理的领导者。你能告诉我们它是如何运作的吗？切诺基卫生系统是一家联邦合格的健康中心和社区心理健康中心。我们有一个临床服务交付模式，它有一个综合医疗保健服务的范式。这意味着在实际操作中，当人们来到我们的诊所时，事实上，即使当他们打电话进来时，他们所有的医疗保健需求都会得到评估。
And so when at the point of care, when someone comes in for primary care services, if there are any behavioral health issues, any health care issues that require behavioral health intervention, that person is able to access that service immediately on the spot in the exam room. And so think about how powerful that is for someone to come into their medical doctors office and to say, hey, I'm having a lot of stress at work, or I'd like to lose weight, or, man, I'm getting these migraines and having a really hard time, even though I'm taking medication in managing it, rather than just getting a card or a template to make an appointment
因此，在护理点，当有人来寻求初级保健服务时，如果有任何行为健康问题，任何需要行为健康干预的医疗保健问题，那个人能够立即在检查室现场获得该服务。所以想想这对某人来说是多么强大，他们来到他们的医生办公室说，嘿，我在工作中压力很大，或者我想减肥，或者，天哪，我得了偏头痛，尽管我正在服药，但在管理它方面真的很困难，而不是仅仅得到一张卡片或模板去预约
somewhere else in the future. In that moment, a psychologist is able to come and speak with you and help you set some goals, learn some behavioral strategies to manage those issues. So as a psychologist, which you are, what's your role on the patient-centered care team? I think psychologists have a tremendous amount to offer on a patient-centered medical team or patient-centered health care team. And the psychological contributions can range from certainly providing direct clinical services and assessment within that health care environment. So in the trenches, seeing patients conducting assessments, providing interventions and consulting with the health care team to improve the quality of care and provide access to care to each individual patient and their family.
将来在其他地方。在那一刻，心理学家能够过来与你交谈，帮助你设定一些目标，学习一些行为策略来管理这些问题。那么作为一名心理学家，也就是你，你在以患者为中心的护理团队中的角色是什么？我认为心理学家在以患者为中心的医疗团队或以患者为中心的医疗保健团队中可以提供巨大的价值。心理学的贡献范围可以从当然在医疗保健环境中提供直接的临床服务和评估。所以在一线，看病人、进行评估、提供干预措施，并咨询医疗团队以提高护理质量，并为每一位患者及其家人提供护理服务。
But the role of psychology in a patient-centered medical home is much broader than that. Psychologists can be involved in the program development and program evaluation component of PCMH. As we discussed, quality and safety are key aspects and fundamental elements of a PCMH. And so evaluating whether or not the interventions and the services provided are effective, not only for an individual, but for an entire panel of patients, such as all the diabetics in the practice, or everyone in the practice who has diagnosis of hypertension. Also, we discussed the program development component. Part of what happens in the PCMH is an expectation of taking care of a population.
但心理学在以患者为中心的医疗之家中的作用远不止于此。心理学家可以参与PCMH的项目开发和项目评估部分。正如我们所讨论的，质量和安全是PCMH的关键方面和基本要素。因此，评估所提供的干预措施和服务是否有效，不仅对个人，而且对整个患者群体，例如诊所里的所有糖尿病患者，或诊所里所有被诊断患有高血压的人。此外，我们讨论了项目开发部分。PCMH中发生的一部分是照顾人群的期望。
So that means that a psychologist can get involved in developing an overall program such as group interventions, protocols and guidelines, health education aids, teaching aids for patients that can help address the population health in agriculture. not individual or by individual. We know that depression has a high level of disease burden for the patient. That is to say, you know, recognizing when a patient is depressed and getting them effective treatment is very important. Is patient-centered care better at treating depression than traditional health care?
这意味着心理学家可以参与开发整体项目，例如小组干预、协议和指南、健康教育辅助工具、可以帮助解决人群健康的教学辅助工具，而不是针对个人。我们知道抑郁症对患者有很高的疾病负担。也就是说，你知道，识别患者何时抑郁并让他们获得有效的治疗非常重要。以患者为中心的护理在治疗抑郁症方面是否比传统医疗保健更好？
Well, certainly the data suggests that when we engage the patient in the process of their own health, that we take a partnership approach rather than a top. down, you know, I will tell you what to do approach, that we're going to see better outcomes, that once patients are engaged, and particularly in a condition like depression in which it's too easy, it's so easy for the patient to be passive and feel helpless and feel like something needs to be done, you know, to them. So certainly what we found is that partnering with the patient, having a patient-centered approach can markedly improve the likelihood of developing and implementing management, depression management program, intervention and treatment
嗯，当然数据表明，当我们让患者参与到他们自身健康的过程中时，我们采取的是一种伙伴关系方法，而不是自上而下的“我会告诉你该怎么做”的方法，我们将看到更好的结果，一旦患者参与进来，特别是在像抑郁症这样的疾病中，患者太容易变得被动、感到无助，并觉得需要对他们做些什么。所以当然我们发现，与患者合作，采取以患者为中心的方法可以显著提高开发和实施管理、抑郁症管理项目、干预和治疗
plan, that's a really good fit for that specific patient. And we, you know, we recognize one size does not fit all. And so partnering with the patient helps us do that. The other thing that is really critical about patient-centered medical home and depression is that we recognize that depression is related to so many other health issues. And so if we can address those other health issues, number one, we may be able to also improve the depression, certainly when we all feel that physically. You know, it's hard to feel good mentally.
计划的可能性，这非常适合该特定患者。而且我们，你知道，我们认识到“一刀切”并不适用。因此，与患者合作有助于我们做到这一点。关于以患者为中心的医疗之家和抑郁症，另一件非常关键的事情是，我们认识到抑郁症与其他许多健康问题有关。因此，如果我们能解决这些其他健康问题，第一，我们也许也能改善抑郁症，当然当我们所有人身体上都感到那样时。你知道，心理上很难感觉良好。
And vice versa, that if we can address and improve the depressive symptoms, we certainly can help someone manage their health better and by extension improve their clinical outcomes for their other health conditions. Well, Dr. Katri, thank you so much for joining us. It's been a pleasure. Thank you very much. For more information on integrated health care and patient-centered medical care, please visit our website at speakingofpsychology.org.
反之亦然，如果我们能解决并改善抑郁症状，我们当然可以帮助某人更好地管理他们的健康，并进而改善他们其他健康状况的临床结果。好吧，科特里博士，非常感谢您加入我们。这真是太愉快了。非常感谢。有关综合医疗保健和以患者为中心的医疗护理的更多信息，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。
With the American Psychological Association, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是美国心理学会《心理学谈话》的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。